fatwa hunted in america pam geller well
we've been following this you have been
telling everybody that we'll listen
about this evil sick ideology it is
and what geraldo and dr gork are talking
about the use of the internet
talk about well listen this is why i
wrote the book because the american
people are being disarmed
in the war of ideas they're being
disarmed in the information battle space
initially new york authorities and mayor
de blasio denied that it was jihad
terror
and this follows a pattern in the west
they deny that jihad terror is jihad
terror and even when it's
obviously jihad terror they still
continue to deny it
the problem is not trucks and rental
companies the problem is not guns and
it's not knives the problem is the
ideology
and there are no lone wolves in the
global jihad they're all
soldiers and what is the internet but a
means of communication
the problem is the jihadic doctrine he
was yelling aloo akbar that was
muhammad's
jihadist war cry his last name by the
way if you're watching cnn it was
uh a little different he was witness
suspect was yelling god is great
in arabic like oh yeah and his last name
was
which means sword of allah and i'm sure
when he was vetted by immigration
authorities they knew that this man was
moderate and they knew that his name
meant that the fact is muslim
immigration
means more islamic terrorism it's just
that simple president trump
has tried to impose national security
restrictions
and again the leftist islamic alliance
has has opposed it
all they want to do is vet let's vet
them dr gorkar hear you
yeah so what what um was just said is
incredibly important
i've worked with the nypd i've worked
with the pavement pounders in the bureau
it's full of patriots but when the
commissioner
of the nypd refuses
to say what it was that this attacker
shouted
at the press conference what is he
saying
about americans is he saying we're too
stupid to understand
or is he continuing the political
correctness when governor cuomo
within minutes minutes of the attack
says there is no broader
broader conspiracy this is a lone
attacker governor
there is no way on god's earth is a
great point in minutes of an attack
yeah there's no way he can know that so
well
i think that that is a defeatist notion
the nypd has the best surveillance
uh in in i think in the in the western
world
on various muslims it was dismantled by
care and by mayor de blasio
a jury convicted a muslim jihadi in a
plot to behead me an isis-inspired
attack
there have been numerous
this terrorist attack is the first time
since 9 11
that they've they've gotten anything
like this kind of first success
we are taking prudent actions when you
guys talk about
uh muslims as being the devil you
overlook the fact that we have a
substantial four percent
who said that why do i have to pat on
the back every muslim that doesn't want
to kill me
four percent of our population we're not
talking about
stop conflating them together stop blood
brushing muslims all
as jihadists of our population is
muslim-american
you're not going to stop that's
irrelevant from start from self-starting
themselves
on this ideology what you have to do now
is good police work
good surveillance pass those sections of
the patriot act that have lapsed
and stereotyping remember that at the
election booth